in our eye on earth series we look at
the real-world consequences of the
environmental catastrophe laid out in
the dire UN climate change report just
out this morning one place already under
threat is California's iconic coastline
Jonathan Vigliotti traveled hundreds of
miles from San Diego up to Pacifica
that's just south of San Francisco to
see the effects Jonathan good morning to
you what you find and good morning to
you Gail we've been on the road for two
days arriving here in Pacifica last
night to what we thought would be an
idyllic beach and instead finding what
looks like a disaster zone what you're
looking at is a seawall it was built ten
years ago meant to last for decades to
come
but the ocean ripped it apart it's now
being rebuilt to protect the homes that
sit above this cliff from our travels I
could tell you this is hardly an
isolated case from Mexico to Oregon
California's rugged Coast runs more than
3,400 miles we're starting here in San
Diego we're gonna be driving about 600
of them to show you how this state is
getting ready for what scientists call
an inevitable future our first up is Del
Mar it's a small beach community about
20 miles north of San Diego we maintain
the lagoon principal planner Amanda Lee
says her town wants to dump additional
sand on this Beach over the next decade
at a total cost of about six million
dollars if we do nothing at this time as
soon as the year 2060 we could
potentially lose our Beach there's more
at risk than just homes here in Del Mar
at the top of this 50-foot bluff more
than 4 million people every single year
ride rails that fit precariously close
to the edge our next up is the city of
insurance about 60 miles north of Los
Angeles you can see where the Pacific
ate away at a bike path officials ripped
it up they put rocks in its place and
actually moved it inland about 60 feet
just this took more than 25 years and
cost about five million dollars not a
single home was involved just a bike
path
when homes get involved private
neighborhood groups build sea walls but
those come with a big downside says UC
Santa Barbara's Charles Lester when you
build the seawall and you try to stop
that erosion you're gonna lose your
Beach over the long term so the choice
we're facing in a lot of places is sea
walls and no beach or something else up
the coast near San Simeon were erosion
averages five feet a year we literally
reached the end of the road so the state
chose to do something else we're talking
about a realignment of State Route 1
about 2.8 miles that we moved inland
about 475 feet the price tag to move a
world-famous highway 55 million dollars
mother nature was also loud and clear up
the coast in Pacifica just south of San
Francisco so far at least nine homes and
three cliffside apartment buildings have
been condemned and demolished all of the
struggles that we've had with erosion
are going to be exacerbated over the
next 20 50 hundred years and compared to
the world average California is actually
expected to get more extreme sea level
rise scientists say by 2100 this area
could get as much as nine feet Tony that
puts at risk about 150 billion dollars
worth of property Wow Jonathan just can
very concerning and 100 or a billion
people around the world face similar
consequences from rising seas important
message here on UN climate Week Jonathan
thank you very much